me
[音楽]
こんばんは
8時になりましたニュースのお時間です
昨夜未明静岡市在住の受賞映像クリエイター
肇社長の自宅に年齢不詳の20代の男が突然彼の家に訪れ
雇ってほしいと言いながら彼の家の前にいられる事件が発生しました
静岡市在住の肇社長の自宅には近年
中学生や小学生が訪れ迷惑しているというニュースはよく聞きますが
就職活動で彼の自宅に人が訪れたのは県内初の事件になります
警察は犯人の身元の特定および琴民への聞き込みを開始しておりません
また事件当時現場に
は自宅に訪れていたはじめ者増資の従業員3名で対応された模様です
容疑者は震えた声で雇ってほしいと連呼しており十人を含む従業員さんいれば恐怖で
怯えていた模様です
エリア取っておいていきましょうことですさあくっ
チョップっていうかわだや大麻草
まだナーダメっ
ちょっと待ってるんですよね
ていた
って
まあ
あいやいやとってほしい気持ちはことですけどさぁ
したリターンを突いてくださいすぐ過呼吸みたいになったんですよ
ましたやったらなぜかのファンで記者ならいいですね
やっぱりしてい
傳甫件いてたら
またありないんですよ行ったら会えるってなりますよん確か
僕はいかないようですよ
普通の服俺上で分かったんやと言いましょうって危険だ加工れてきます
いやでもマジは普通に考えると観光としてますからねまあソード家に行くこと時点で
最適な
私のですから
を考えると厳しいんで迫がや不採用ということで正しい
面接をしたんでさよ
現場と儒教がつながっております
はいこちら事件現場からの中継です
こちらが事件のあった
枝一さんのお宅です
現場では一晩経った今も依然として騒然としており近隣住民が外へ出る様子はみられ
ません
また犯人の夢もつかめておらず警察は厳戒な態勢で捜査を進めておりません
以上テーマ軽くするう
can
また近隣の住人からも心配の声が上がっています
だからを言ってたろなあーだからそういう奴が一番アズゲート枚クリティカパンサー
ほんと使えねーから1台は本当
に声よなほんとな給食が
チェルチなくっちゃはず集中出来たってくれるぞ
あっ墓魚ば現在順番好きでは警備の強化を進めており調査に含める系8000人態勢で
現場の調査及び犯人の行方を追っております
[音楽]
me
teame
mar
me
uh